Welcome back.
We're on problem number 15.
And I've tried it as best
as I can to draw it.
And they're pretty much saying--
well, I'll read it--
Doug's biology experiment
involving timing 12
hamsters in a maze.
Each hamster received at
least one practice
before being timed.
The scatter plot above shows the
time each hamster took to
complete the maze and the
corresponding number of
practices that each
hamster received.
Based on the data, which of the
following functions best
models the relationship between
t, the number of
seconds to complete the maze--
this is the t-axis-- and p,
the number of practices?
This is p, the number
of practices.
So we want to find t
as a function of p.
So t is a function of p.
So, one, it looks like the
hamsters didn't learn much
when they got practice.
No matter how much practice
they got, the hamsters, it
looks like they roughly took
about the same amount of time.
We could try to draw a line
here that fits this curve.
Maybe it would look something
like this.
I don't know, something
like that.
I mean, it's not going to be--
you could try to be cute and
try to draw something maybe with
a little bit of a slope
or anything, but I mean, really,
this looks like a flat
line when you look at it.
So what would be the equation
of that line?
Well, the equation of
that line would be
like 45 or 44 or something.
So if you said t of p is equal
to-- and actually, they have a
choice that looks just like
that-- t of p is equal to 44.
No matter how many practices
the mice got, regardless of
how many, they on average
take roughly 44 seconds.
So practice doesn't really help
mice much, as opposed to
students preparing
for the SAT.
And all of the other ones
don't make any sense.
I mean, t of p equals p.
That would be something
like this.
Choice A is something like
that, that has no sense.
No, sorry, choice
A is our answer.
Choice B looks something
like that.
Choice C, 44p.
That will be even
a super steep.
That makes no sense.
P/44, that's going to be like
a really shallow graph.
And then you could
have p plus 44.
That would start here and then
have a slope of 1, so it would
look like that.
So none of the other ones
are even close.
So it's definitely choice A.
t of p is equal to 44.
Last problem.
And I'll do a new color.
Problem 16.
And they drew this thing,
so I have a big square.
And then we have a
square like that.
Actually, I should just
use the line tool,
that would be better.
A square like that.
And then I have a square
like that, roughly.
It's not perfectly drawn because
these three squares
look the same, and they tell
us they're the same.
They tell us that this is W.
And this is L.
W, W, W.
L, L.
The pattern shown above is
composed of rectangles.
This pattern is used repeatedly
to completely cover
a rectangular region 12 units
long and 11 units wide.
So they're covering a region
that's 12L long and 10L wide.
So this is like a thumbnail
of the floor.
How many rectangles of dimension
L by W are needed?
OK.
Well, when they say how many
rectangles of dimension L by
W, that's just each of
these rectangles
that they drew here.
Right?
Because all of these have
dimensions L by W, L by W, L
by W, L by W, L by W, right?
So if we could figure out just
how many of these-- this
pattern has 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
of those on it, right?
So if we could just figure out
how many of this pattern would
fit onto this, then
we're done.
So how can we figure that out?
So do we know a relationship
between L and W?
Well, sure.
We see here that two L's are the
same thing as three W's.
We know that 2L is equal
to three W's.
And since all our dimensions
are given in L, let's solve
for W and substitute.
So let's say that W is equal
to-- just divide both sides by
3-- W is equal to 2/3 L.
All I said is 2L is the
same thing as 3W and I
divided it by 3.
So W is equal to 2/3 L.
So can we represent the height
and the width of this
rectangle now in terms
of only L's?
Well, sure.
What's the height?
What's the length of
this rectangle?
Well, the length is definitely
just 2L, right?
L plus L.
That's the length.
And what's the width?
Well, W is what?
It's 2/3 L plus L, so what's the
width of this rectangle?
What's 2/3 of something plus
1 whole of that something?
Or 2/3 plus 3/3?
So the width is 5/3 L.
So each of these rectangles
is 5/3 L by 2L.
So how many of these rectangles
are we going to
have to put onto this floor?
How many total?
Well, going in this dimension
they have a length of 2L.
So if we have to-- if they're
2L each, then we're going to
need six of them, right?
We're going to need 6
in this direction.
Because we're going to go a
total distance of 12L, and
they're 2L each.
So they're going to be
6 in that direction.
And how many are we going to
need in this direction?
Well, we have to go a total
distance of 10L.
And the width of each
of them is 5/3 L.
So what's 10 divided by 5/3?
So the L's cancel out.
So 10 divided by 5/3 is the same
thing as 10 times 3/5.
And that just equals 6.
So we're going to need
6 rectangles in this
direction as well.
So how many total rectangles
are we going to need?
Well, 6 times 6 is equal
to 36 total rectangles.
And then, how many of these
smaller rectangles
are in each of these?
We'll need 36 of this pattern.
And then how many of the
rectangles are in that pattern?
Well, we counted.
There's 5.
So we're going to need 5 times
36 total of these smaller
rectangles.
So 5 times 36 is what?
150 plus 30?
It's 180.
We will need 180 of these
smaller rectangles.
So that is choice E.
And we are done with
this test three.
I'll see you in test four.